- I know what you're doing,
so don't give me some
fucking sob story here.
I know what the fuck is happening here!
They may be confused and make
fun of me for interrupting.
I'm the least confused
fucker you'll ever meet.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(hip hop music)
Hey guys, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
So, in this new year, in 2020,
we're doing a bunch of different formats
for the podcast and content,
not just kinda putting
it all under the umbrella
of "The Ask Gary Vee Show,"
which is super ironic,
because this episode of
"The Audio Experience"
we're gonna be interviewing a author,
but the 100%, I'm sure Colin
is so uncomfortably remarkable,
and we'll find that all out,
but 100% of the reasons
that he is sitting here
is because India,
the former star of "The
Ask Gary Vee Show,"
now works with him, 'cause she moved,
for all you super hardcore,
O.G., "Ask Gary Vee" fans,
India's actually in studio,
so I know you're all fired up,
but this part of the
conversation is about Colin.
So Colin, for everybody who is listening,
give them the kind of
framework of who you are,
and what this book that
just came out is about,
and then we'll get into some jamming.
- Yeah, absolutely Gary,
it's great to be here,
and we are grateful to
have India on the team.
She moved to the West Coast,
my hometown, Portland, Oregon,
so I guess that's a little
bit where my story starts.
I'm from Portland, Oregon.
The book that came out today
is called The Impossible First:
From Fire to Ice,
Crossing Antarctica Alone.
I, last year, became the
very person in history
to cross Antarctica solo,
completely unsupported,
and unaided, so no outside support.
I had to carry all my
food and fuel with me,
375 pound sled, 54 days all alone.
Adventurers and explorers
have been attempting this feat
for over 100 years and people
have died attempting it.
No one had ever been able to do it before
and I kinda cracked the
code and was able to do it.
- So the ones that didn't die
would just quit and turn around?
- Yeah or like run out of
food or run out of supplies
and call for support.
Obviously getting support or pick up
in the middle of Antarctica
is not an easy thing but it can be done.
You can be extracted but the
reason the title's called
From Fire to Ice is 12 years ago actually,
the book came out today
but it's also the 12 year anniversary
of a tragic accident in my life.
I was severely burned in a
fire 12 years ago in Thailand
and the doctors told me I
would never walk again normally
so it's humbling but
also a proud day to know
that diagnosis was wrong.
I was able to recover from
that and achieve some things
on the other end of it that
I never thought were possible
at the time.
- So, how'd you do it?
- (laughs) I know it's stuff
that you talk a lot about
but it's really the power of the mind.
The mindset for me --
- [Gary] I believe in that shit.
- [Colin] Was the difference --
- Can you answer something
for me that will finally
like help me in my life?
- Yes.
- Is being cold a mindset?
You know, I think that
you can definitely --
- Because I don't wear coats, right?
- [Colin] Yeah.
- And everybody like
makes fun of me for this
and then I'm always like,
but I'm from Belarus,
and I make this joke that
like I was from Russia so,
but I don't believe that.
- Do you get cold?
- Not if I don't want to.
- Right, right.
I mean so the average
temperature in Antarctica
was about -30 degrees every single day.
I was pulling my sled 12 plus hours a day,
windchill -70 degrees
and I was out there alone
for two months and I didn't end up
with any severe frostbite
of anything like that,
a few little frost nips on my nose.
I'm not sure it was all in my mind.
I wasn't walking out
there completely naked.
Wim Hof did a blurb the
book but I don't know
if you could make it
completely naked out there
but definitely was able
to keep myself warm,
particularly when you're
pulling a 375 pound sled.
- And that's the point, right?
It's not a binary thing, to your point,
it's not like you're gonna like, I was,
I guess my punchline is this,
I'm, I failed all my science
classes so that didn't put me
in a position to really know the answer
to any of these questions
but on my intuition,
I'm wildly fascinated by people
underestimating the power of the brain.
- Absolutely.
I mean, that's where --
- That feels so right to me
and even the reaction of
the room, like I don't,
bro, I really believe in it.
- That's, I mean, that's my truth.
That's why I said from
fire to ice, people say,
how did you get out of
this Thai hospital so,
go deeper into the book
obviously but real quick,
I was jumping a flaming
jump rope in Thailand
when I was 22 years old,
not the brightest move ever.
- You told me this story, right?
- Yeah, I think I've told you this before.
- [Colin] Rope wrapped around my legs.
- Remind me where we crossed paths on this
because I know this story
and like when you started telling it,
I'm like fuck, I know this story --
- [Colin] Yeah.
- And I was like I know this story.
- Yeah, I've been in here before.
I know AJ a little bit.
We've got a mutual
friend in Steph Bagley --
- That's right when you
were talking about like,
right and like the Nike guy and all that.
I was like sitting here I'm like, man,
why is this like so obvious to me.
- Yes, yes, Swan Sit's
one of my dear friends.
I had dinner with her last night.
Shout out to Swan.
- [Gary] She's awesome.
- I know she's a dear friend of yours.
So got a lot of mutual folks.
But anyways 12 years ago, yeah,
so the rope wraps around my legs,
lit my body completely on fire to my neck,
have to dive into the ocean
to extinguish the flames.
I'm on a tiny little island in Thailand.
There's no proper hospital,
moped ride to a dirt path --
- I think I asked you
this at the time but like,
why did that happen?
Why'd you fuck up on the rope?
- (laughs) Thousands of
people do that every night
in Thailand and I just
had bad luck, you know,
excess kerosene on the rope
and it just splattered me
and lit me on fire but the
piece about the mindset
that was key was in that hospital,
there was a cat running
around my bed in the ICU,
mom's saying, you know,
the doctor's saying to me,
you'll never walk again
normally and my mother,
incredible woman that she is,
she flies all the way over to
Thailand to kind of rescue me,
she walks in the room,
she's crying in the hallways
pleading for good news
from the doctor but she
shields me from that fear.
She walks in, she goes,
Colin, like what's your goal?
What do you wanna do with the rest of it,
you're 22 years old?
Your life is not over
and I was kind of like,
I don't know.
I'm like dark, deep dark
spiral, downward spiral.
She's like, "No, seriously.
"What is your goal?"
And I go, close my eyes
and I was like, mom,
I just visualized myself
crossing the finish line
of a triathlon and I figured
she was gonna look at me
and go like, yeah, I said set
a goal but look at your legs
and the doctor said you're
not gonna walk again
and she goes, "All right,
if that's your goal,
"let's do that.
"Let's talk about it everyday.
"Let visualize it, let's
get it in your mind."
- Did you give a shit about
triathlon's before then?
- I'd never done it before.
I'd swam in college but
like, just in my mind,
when I figured like what's a fit person,
I guess I got a highlight
reel of the Kona Ironman
or something popped into my head.
I'd never done a triathlon
before and so, you know,
it's a long story but --
- When did you do this?
- This, so the Antarctica
crossing was last year.
What the book is really about
but the burn accident --
- When I saw you, you
hadn't done it yet, right,
or you did?
- Hadn't done that yet.
I had a couple other world
records in mountaineering.
- Yeah, I remember.
Did you tell me you were
going to, I'm trying to,
I remember, I'm remembering a
lot more about that meeting,
did you say you were going to or it --
- I had just come off a
different world record project
where I set the speed record
for climbing the tallest mountain
on each of the seven continents
and going to the North and South Pole.
- Yep.
- So that was called The
Explorer's Grand Slam
but then going all the way
back to the burn accident
in 2009, 2010, I was recovering from that,
moved to Chicago because I needed a job.
I was a commodities
trader for a quick minute.
- [Gary] Colin --
- Yeah?
- Real quick.
You're really good at
doing crazy ass shit.
You know what I'm really good at?
Selling books.
- All right, let's sell these books.
- Here's how we're gonna do it.
You're not gonna tell
the whole fucking book
in this fucking podcast.
- [Colin] I'm not gonna
tell the whole book!
- So we're done with that story.
We're going somewhere else.
- [Colin] All right, let's do it.
- You're probably gonna
do 800 other things
where you'll tell the whole things.
Everybody, please just
buy this book for India.
Okay, so, Colin, talk to me about this:
where does like, I
actually want you to go,
it's funny now I'm like vibing
and that's why I interrupted you heavy.
- I love it.
- By the way, India,
you're gonna love this.
We're launching "Interrupted by Gary Vee"
as my interview show.
(group laughs)
Yes.
Right?
Because, look, I have to own it.
Like, yeah, because you
know what they're gonna say.
I know, it's a gift and a curse.
All right, listen --
- I love it, I'm with it.
Let's ride.
Let's sell these books.
- All right, Colin, talk to me, how much,
I want you to go very real
'cause I think you can actually
help a lot, you help a lot
of people through this,
I'm gonna give you a curve ball
that I think you're gonna hit
and bring a lot of value
'cause I think this is
very interesting to me.
How much of what you're
going through right now
do you think about in like
a personal brand Evil Knievel way?
- Personal brand, Evil Knievel way, yeah.
- How much in the way you're strategizing,
you're living this life now.
You're so young still.
You were young at 22
laying there with fire
and now you're young again.
- [Colin] Yes.
- You're putting these wins on the board.
You've figured out a way
to play with your brain
that's making shit happen.
- [Colin] Yep.
- You've got this book
that's gonna do well.
- Here's what I'll say,
here's what I'll say, this,
is that my wife, Jenna
Besaw, she's in the room.
She is really not only my
wife, an incredible person,
but my business partner and her and I,
and we do talk about this
in the book and I think
this appeals to your audience,
I'm not gonna talk about the book,
I'm gonna say but this --
- It's okay.
You can talk.
I was having a joke, go ahead.
- The ideas is --
- Actually, Colin, can you stop?
Can you read the book
verbatim here right now
for the rest of this interview?
- Yeah, the entire thing, hold on.
So page one,
(group laughs)
Colin O'Brady,
Fire to Ice: Crossing Antarctica Alone.
- Go ahead.
- Um, no so --
- Actually, are you doing an audio book?
- I read it myself.
- [Gary] Good for you.
That's where I was gonna go.
- I'm gonna read the
first line 'cause I think
you might enjoy it.
- [Gary] I believe I will.
- The first line of the book is,
I started thinking about my hands.
That was my first mistake.
Boom!
You're in, man, you're in!
- I do like that!
I do like that!
I'm in!
You said, boom, you're
in a little too fast.
If you waiting a hundredth of a beat,
I would've been more in.
- [Colin] I should've let
it breathe for a second.
- But go ahead, go ahead, go ahead.
- No, but one thing that
we talk about in this book
which is we frame it as from
whiteboard into reality.
- Yes.
- Because this book, remember it is about,
it is about the adventure and the feat
but Jenna and I sat in
a one bedroom apartment,
had no money, had nothing about,
know nothing about marketing,
branding, any of this stuff.
The first project we were
gonna do was gonna cost
a half a million dollars.
We have $10,000 to our name
of life savings and I go,
"We're gonna do this project."
We go, wait, we don't know anything
about marketing and PR.
We literally pull our
laptops and we go, Google,
what's the difference
between marketing and PR?
I mean we were asking
the most basic questions.
We're like, the internet's here.
Like let's just start figuring shit out.
- Let's write that article so
we show up first on Google.
- (laughs) And so literally
that starts happening and we go,
we start talking to people.
We need sponsorship, we need funding.
Talk to a thousand people, no, no, no.
You have 200 Instagram followers,
why would we be a part of this?
No, no, no, but we kept hustling.
We kept grinding.
We finally found a couple people
to believe in us and this,
and now we've pulled out
projects at a massive scale
but it started there.
- It's how every single thing happens.
Everybody thinks it's like
manifesting, the secret,
no, here it is.
You know what you're trying to accomplish
and then you have the
humility to do the steps
to accomplish it which
causes you to deploy
an incredible amount of patience
and an incredible amount
of grind and dirt.
- Absolutely and that's, I mean --
- And asking, at scale.
- Oh, asking so many people --
- And recognizing, so
I talk a lot about ask,
DM people, ask,
and I get so much pushback
from people after they do it!
- [Colin] Yeah.
- Like, I read my DMs.
I read my stuff.
Gary, you're fucking,
you told me to DM 50 fucking famous people
to eat shit and be their admin,
get close to the fucking
sun, you fucking asshole,
this, that, the other thing,
de, de, de, de, de,
and I'm like, and like every
time I just reply back,
I'm like dude,
you want to be the next fucking
great director in Hollywood
and you think that you,
you gave up after DMing
50 people on Instagram
while taking a shit on a Thursday?
Fuck you!
(group laughs)
- After we had said, after we had said,
a thousand people had said no to us,
we had only raised --
- [Gary] That was funny actually.
Can we clip that out,
it'll do well on Instagram.
- We'd only raised 150 grand,
I'm leaving in six weeks,
we need the other 350,000
and I'm still doing press.
I'm like, I'm doing this.
I'm ready, let's go.
- [Gary] I love it.
- Let's keep knocking on
doors and I'm not gonna
give away the whole
thing in the book but --
- Stop it.
Stop, we're gonna stop,
I'm not letting you stop.
I wanna clip it.
Do you think like Evil Knievel?
Like do you think --
- No.
- [Gary] Okay.
- The truth is no.
- [Gary] Okay, good.
- To me, I am not framing this
around me doing more stunts
and people watching me.
What I want with this book
and the way the book is written --
- To inspire.
- Really, no, this is true.
- [Gary] Yeah, please.
- This is candid, is the book
is called The Impossible First
but it is not me, yes,
it's edge of your seat
adventure storytelling,
you'll like it, it's a page turner,
it's an epic story whatever, however --
- Who wrote it?
- Hold on, let me, I wanna finish.
- Bro, it's not how my brain works!
- I know you're interrupting
but let me finish
this one thought.
This one thought, please, let me.
- Bro, you can do that one thought
8,000 other fucking places
than my fucking show
you asked to be on.
You used fucking India.
You used fucking India to get on,
you hired India to use
India to be on this show!
- See, I'm continuing --
- Bro, I know what you're doing!
- Whiteboarding to reality, bro!
- I know what you're
doing so don't give me
some fucking sob story here.
I know what the fuck is happening here!
(group laughs)
They may be confused and make
fun of me for interrupting,
I'm the least confused
fucker you'll ever meet.
- It was on my whiteboard,
it said I wanna meet Gary Vee
and I said, "Shit, I better hire the girl
"that she's moving to the west coast,"
and here it is, reality.
That's what I was gonna say.
That's the last chapter of
the book but, no, for real,
I'm asking your question is
about Evil Knievel which is,
it would be easy for us to
frame our brand, candidly,
it would be easy to be like,
here's a dude that does bad ass shit.
Watch him do bad ass shit.
Like David Goggins, respect,
like his brand is like on fire.
- Is that what he does?
- I mean, he's just the
bad ass motherfucker
who does hardcore stuff like --
- You love him, right?
- [Colin] You know, and like --
- Somebody on our team loves him.
- A lot of people are motivated by him.
I'm just saying, no knock on him at all,
at all, mad respect.
- No, no, I think you're giving him a lot,
you're giving him a ton of love.
- Tons of love.
- Everybody's got the
thing they like doing.
- For me, like --
- [Gary] I like garage saling.
- My heart is not fully in that.
After doing this just two weeks ago,
I just got back from rowing
a boat across Drake Passage,
700 miles to Antarctica
in a tiny little rowboat.
No one in the world's
ever done that either
but I'm not sitting here telling
you that story necessarily.
- But why are you putting
that W on the board?
I'm fascinated.
It's really clever and I don't think it's,
I'm sorry, clever's not fair.
I'm fascinated to, you
just brought that up, why?
Like what are you doing?
- Here's what I think.
Here's my thesis, my thesis is this.
- What do you think you're doing?
- My thesis is this --
- [Gary] Please.
- Is that my canvas, if I
think of myself as an artist,
is endurance sports and the outdoors.
I love doing that.
I'm passionate about it.
It makes my heart sing.
- You're good at it.
- I'm good at it.
- [Gary] Clearly.
- However I think the mindset,
the skills, the creativity,
the hustle, whatever you wanna call that,
can be manifested in any modality,
that could be entrepreneurship,
that could be love,
that could be business
and I call this book
The Impossible First, I hope
that people put this book down,
this is not bullshit and
not like pat me on the back,
be like, Colin, you're an amazing athlete.
You have 10 world records, you're so cool.
Like that is not an ROI for me.
The ROI is when someone puts
this book down and goes,
I'm gonna do my impossible first.
I'm actually gonna not
just DM those 50 people
while I'm taking a crap --
- You want, you want
admiration and legacy.
- I want admiration and legacy,
I actually want the ripple
effect of positivity
of people actually doing stuff.
- I understand, for what?
You've got to understand like, for me,
I want admiration and legacy.
- You wanna own the Jets, bro!
- No, I do not.
I want the game of owning the Jets
and then when I own the
Jets, 'cause I will,
you wanna own the Jets, too?
- [Female] Yes.
- Okay, well,
- [Female] For real.
- Is it a race or do you
wanna like jump on board?
(group laughs)
- [Female] Well, I'm down to collaborate.
- Got it.
I'm not.
I'm very selfish on this one.
I'm collabing on everything else.
I think, I think, you know
it's really interesting,
it took me a long time to
know, I'm listening to you,
I'm, I always see the world
through optimism and cynicism, right?
- [Colin] Yep.
- And I always say to myself, like,
it took me a long, long
time and I'm like, fuck,
why am I like this?
Like why am I not as motivated by money,
even though I'm this entrepreneur?
Why did I create this thing
called I wanna buy the Jets
for the whole world?
To make everybody
completely confused to think
that's what I'm actually up to.
That was your answer
as somebody who knows,
like my deep wants and needs
are to have admiration and legacy.
I want all the best shit
that ever happens to me
to happen to me when I
know that it didn't happen
meaning after I'm dead.
Like to me,
but that's like a fascinating
thing to understand why.
Like I'm like,
why do I want all the
coolest shit to happen
where I don't even get to see it?
- You wanna look back on it?
Like is it for you, for
your kids or your family,
the generations beyond you?
- I think, back to buying the Jets,
my current hypothesis 'cause you know
this is a forever fucking game,
whenever you're doing something
even slightly outside the lane,
you're stuck asking
yourself what the fuck?
The lane's so easy.
- Sure.
- This is hard.
- Absolutely.
- You know, my intuition is,
actually the statue when I'm dead
is exactly like buying the Jets.
I'm obsessed with process
and I kinda like this idea that when,
the end of my process is
actually the end of my life.
- [Colin] Sure.
- And so I, there's just
this deep curiosity of like,
okay that'll be it.
That'll be triple zero
and like and then what?
- But that's for you but if,
there's no finish line, right?
Like there's no finish line.
You wanna continue to grow and evolve
and continue to keep stepping
outside that comfort zone.
- Always, always.
- And that's what it is for me.
After setting two world
records in the mountain,
it was like okay --
- But what's in it for you?
- But for me, the next --
- Like to me, that's what is
interesting because I think,
I think we in society need to start
having a better relationship
of the ability to hold
both selfish and selfless acts in one.
We've become a binary culture
where it's black, white,
left, right, yes, no, and
I think we've completely
gotten into a place
where we do not have more
nuance conversations.
I am fascinated,
my ability to be selfless
through my selfish wants
and needs of admiration.
- Well, I would say this.
You're saying and I agree with this,
by leading by example,
by actually living your full
truth in your full capacity,
you're actually having a larger impact.
You're having more resources
but also by actually sharing this,
by being on this podcast,
- 100 percent.
- By writing books, by speaking --
- [Gary] 100 percent.
- All the things that you and I both do,
you maybe at a bigger level
but like that actually
inspires people not because you're like,
oh, but it's not about me,
you're like, I'm doing this.
I care about this.
I have conviction.
- Here's actually what's
funny about it and this is why
I think you might be
somebody that might help,
I'm curious if you can
like, I'm hoping like,
I'm hoping you email me
in 13 weeks and be like,
I got something,
because I think it's
an interesting thought.
I think everything's about me.
Which makes everything
I do nothing about me.
- Silence.
- 'Cause it's an interesting thought.
Like let me make it very
clear so it's not confusing.
I only do what I want to
do every minute, the end.
Ironically, quite a bit
of that leads to bringing
an uncomfortable level
of value in comparison
to my contemporaries.
- Sure.
Well, I think that, what
do people say to you --
- I'm to figure that out
so other people can --
- But Gary why?
Right, like people are asking you that,
people ask me, Colin,
why would you walk across Antarctica, why?
To me, it's almost hard for me to answer
'cause it's so obvious why
I would want to do that.
- I would walk across Antarctica
because I just want to
tell motherfuckers like,
yo, fuck you, I walked across Antarctica.
(group laughs)
To me, that's like what's
cool about it, like fuck.
You know, Nate, who's my
partner in Empathy Wines,
who was my admin for many years,
who worked here for a long time.
India knows him well.
- ♪ We don't talk anymore ♪
Oh shit, I gotta FaceTime my kids.
That's what this is.
All right, we're gonna
wrap this up in a minute,
but let me tell this story
and I'll buy you a couple minutes here
to say how much I love you.
- [Colin] All right.
- I like to raz, like he was really,
like I love when I have admin,
India and I have a very
special relationship,
like Team Gary and I are very close
but like when you go into
like even into admin world,
it gets even to like another
deeper thing and so like,
I'm always say about like what works,
like how do I bring people value?
And everybody that I work
with has different things.
Is it like, do you go with radical candor?
Do you go with kindness?
Do you randomly call them?
Do you randomly follow them?
Do you, what do you do?
What do you do to bring
the most value to them?
Talks, are you always there for them?
Do you make them feel like
you are there for them?
Do you try to build, when
they move to Portland,
do you try to make sure
people know about it
so that people do know me want them?
Like, I know what I'm doing, okay?
So, Nate, I would always
like razz about like,
I'm gonna have to go there,
I've beaten Nate in tennis
every time we've played, all right,
and what's even more fun --
- (laughs) Let that be known.
- And let that be known
and, more importantly,
you know, listen 10 world records,
I've beaten Nate every time
I've played him in tennis.
(group laughs)
Number two,
Nate has been beating me in tennis
on three separate occasions,
five to two, to win the set,
which is what we're talking
about because we play one set.
- What happened, in those games?
- I decide mentally not to lose.
Now, to your point that if
I went naked in Antarctica,
I would freeze and die to death.
It wasn't just that because
then I would've never lost
a match in my life!
If I've decided not to
lose, I would never lose.
There's something in the
relationship with me and Nate
that has allowed me to
do that but, anyway,
I would bring this up a
bunch to razz him, razz him,
having fun, real fun like
brother banter type stuff,
and then finally like, I was like,
I gotta like help him figure
out how to like counter me.
So I said, Nate --
- Don't tell me you started
intentionally losing to him?
- Are you out of your fucking mind?
(group laughs)
I said, no, I said, "Nate,
you're a scratch golfer,"
people give a fuck about
golf in society for --
- [Colin] Whatever reason.
- Yeah, people like a
lot of different things,
like I said, "Next time I say
to you and make fun of you
"in front of people, five, two,
"you ask me what my handicap is."
I've never golfed.
I don't even know, like
17 times, maybe 11.
So now he uses that all the time.
- And does it get in your head?
Is it harder for you to
battle back in that set?
- Well, my big thing is like,
everybody's got strengths
and weaknesses and like,
I'm very passionate about people
leaning into their strengths
and then, ultimately,
and this is what's making
this interview fun for me
is I want people who have
emotional intelligence
strengths to really,
I wish that the world out there
that was really compassionate
and empathetic and sympathetic
and kind realize they're the strong
and they can win the whole thing,
they continue to buy into their pushovers
and people walk over them.
That's because they don't
realize that they actually
use kindness as a
manipulation, not as a truth.
They're getting walked
over because they actually
weren't being kind.
Their intent was wrong.
They were trying to create
some sort of scenario
but they did it in a
way that was too obvious
and that's why somebody walked over them.
- But I think, I mean,
I hate to do this but I'm gonna
bring it back to the book.
- [Gary] Please.
- The last chapter of my
book is called Infinite Love
and that is not exactly
what people would expect
from a bad ass dude that goes alone
and does this super hard thing
that no one ever has done
but in harnessing the positivity,
- [Gary] I got it.
- In harnessing the love,
harnessing that compassion,
empathy, my wife, my team, et cetera,
that's what I wanted to
leave behind with this legacy
to go like,
no one can kind of question me in terms
of like the difficulty,
the challenge, what I've
been through, whatever.
- Yes, it's how.
- But it's like, hey,
I got there not from having
the most ruthless chip
on my shoulder.
I'm super ambitious.
I'm gonna knock on a thousand doors
and if I don't get it
on the thousandth time,
I'm gonna knock it on 1,001 but,
at the same time, where my mind went,
I'm starving, my rips are protruding,
I'm running out of food.
I ended up pushing 77
miles in 32 hours straight
on the very last day because
I went to a place in my mind
so deep in flow,
- [Gary] I so get it.
- So deep in commitment
which is what you're saying
about the tennis match.
I'm just not gonna lose and
this was actually a race.
There was another dude
out there battling me.
- I live in that flow.
- [Colin] Right.
- I actually live in that flow.
- And that's the most beautiful place
and most profound place.
- It's something that we
have to, like you know,
it's so funny, I'm so happy meditation,
you know what's really on the rise?
Breathing.
- [Colin] Yes.
- I'm seeing that really, breathing is,
no, really it's on the rise.
People are really starting --
- I'm long-breathing, for sure.
- You know what's funny,
like I've been talking about
meditation for five years
and I'm like, look, I
don't meditate but --
- Dude, you got to.
- But I'm so pumped for other people,
like everybody finds their thing.
Like some people love running.
They get a runner's high, I hear.
I get shin splints in one
second and wanna kill the world.
(group laughs)
Like we all have our things,
like my big thing though,
is like, oh quickly, breathing
is really on the rise,
tons of people are starting to really,
are getting into like
truly like being thoughtful
about breathing.
- I breathe everyday, personally.
- No, no, but listen, I
mean this really cool,
this is really cool to me 'cause
I wanna put this out there
because I want people to dig into it,
this notion of like if you
exhale more than you inhale,
it's like a very basic thought of like,
get your brain thinking that
you're actually resting,
I just have had three separate, three,
three separate friends
who could not sleep,
alcohol, pills, meditation,
reading, different beds,
sound machines, oxygen,
open window, closed window,
new rooms, moving, planes, walking,
I'm going through it all,
three different friends
with some variations of those,
all get into great sleeping behavior
on five minutes of breathing
before they go to bed.
You got something for me on this?
- [Male] Well, Wim Hof's
thing like you mentioned --
- I don't know what we're
talking about but go ahead.
- [Male] He has like
this breathing technique
that's like 10 minutes long.
- This some dude?
- [Male] I do that like --
- He's on the back of the book.
- And that's like a big thing?
- And here this will read,
the impossible first,
that's one urgent question,
with the right mindset,
what is each of us capable of?
- [Gary] And you were super
pumped, you were like,
I'm gonna sell 100K more
copies 'cause of this?
Love it.
- Yeah, he's just breathing
and he's breathing in the cold
and breathing.
- [Male] Yeah, cold showers, breathing.
- You do this shit?
- [Male] Yeah.
- But not all the time
'cause it's hard core?
- [Male] No, twice a day.
- Twice a day you shower cold?
- [Male] Yeah.
- Epic.
- [Colin] Yeah, do hard stuff.
- [Male] I mean it's hard but like,
in the beginning it was really hard,
but now it's gotten --
- Bro, I think everything's easy.
Just fucking talk to yourself into it.
- The meditation, the meditation
that I did to begin this
10 years ago long before I thought
I was ever gonna do this is,
I got introduced, someone
said, "Go meditate."
I never meditated a minute
in my life and I went
and signed up for a 10
day vipassana course,
10 day, no reading, no writing,
no eye contact and, for me,
it was, was it difficult?
Yes but committing to
like, I wanna do this,
I wanna take a deep immersion
and that trained my mind
to have the daily practice that,
what you're talking about Rog
which is actually doing it daily
but taking that deep dive first
to have that full immersion,
most people would say
I'm not gonna do 10 days
unless I earn up to that over time.
- But you'll appreciate this:
And for some people,
that's the way it works.
- [Colin] For sure.
- Right like, here's what
people don't understand.
They listen to podcasts
like this and are like,
yeah, whatever.
What people don't understand is like,
there's 87,000 different ways
that we're not talking about
all the ways that didn't work.
- For sure.
- Like we're sitting
here trying to articulate
all the things that did work.
There's like a million
things that don't work.
It's about action.
- But actually keeping
trying different things
until something works.
- Correct, which goes to self
esteem because so many people
are scared about their loss, publicly.
- For sure.
- How many, in your 10 world records,
how many times have you tried
to create a world record
and not succeed?
- Before I set a single world record,
I spent 20 years of my life
trying to make the Olympics
and I didn't make the Olympics.
I came close, I fell short in two sports,
in swimming and then also in triathlon,
and then I kept reinventing myself
and now I have 10 world records.
- Do you have weird lungs?
Do you have like that weird lung thing?
- (laughs) I breathe well.
- No really, I think the Nike runner guy,
when he passed away, like the guy --
- The big VO2 Max and stuff like that?
- Then they like chopped him
open and he had like ribs,
like lungs --
- So far, I've been tested a lot,
I think I have pretty normal lungs.
I might have slightly better capacity
than the average person but --
- Bro, I fucking hate running.
- Yeah, I heard the shin splints, man.
- Yeah, but that's like a cop out.
- [Colin] Different shoes, maybe.
- I just don't like it.
I love jump rope though.
I'm hot on jump rope right now.
- Yeah?
You gotta breathe the jump rope.
High jump rope, high breathing.
- I hate breathing.
(group laughs)
No really, I know I don't,
I don't like forcing myself to
breathe harder, like I don't,
even like when I was like,
this is recently on my radar
which is why I'm talking about it,
like the whole exhale harder,
I'm like, I don't like that.
It's like (exhales), it's hard.
(group laughs)
You know what I mean?
I like things that come easy.
I actually do, it's a very, back to like,
this is why I think I talk
so much about strengths.
I like the things that come easy to me.
For most people,
they're not a robot and
could work 22 hours in a day
like I did yesterday and,
by the way,
I think everyone should sleep
seven and eight and nine hours.
Yesterday, serendipitously,
'cause I went to the
national championship game
and you gotta go with the fucking
champion LSU players to the club.
If you're in the sports
representation business,
you're fucking in this business and like,
and then my alarm didn't
go off and like fucking,
all sorts of shit happened today,
punchline is most people can't do that.
I have natural energy.
- Heck yeah, yeah.
- So I'm leaning into my natural energy.
Some people are pretty.
Dustin, like I don't know how
that, being a pretty life is,
but you know the advantages of that.
(group laughs)
- [Female] What are you talking about?
- No but really I really
think in wrapping this up,
there's no way, look, there's a,
do I believe that people are listening
who are gonna be like,
I'm gonna do that too.
I do not believe that everyone
was given the same group of talents.
I do think that we should
all challenge ourselves
to be self aware and try
to figure out the talents
and then if we're lucky
that those talents match
something we're interested in doing,
we have to go committed to that.
- What I would say, as a
final thought at least for me,
you're talking about my
lungs, are they bigger,
are they stronger?
Am I tall, I'm pretty, six foot tall guy,
but what I say, I believe,
the strongest muscle that any of us have,
- [Gary] 100 percent.
- Is the six inches between our ears
and that's what we all have.
We are born with a mind
that we can flex and develop
in all sorts of --
- The problem is,
some people go with what they wish it was
versus what it actually is.
The brain can't, listen,
I believe in the brain.
Bro, I actually asked you
'cause I actually was asking,
if cold is a brain thing.
- [Colin] Yeah.
- 'Cause I think it is.
I don't know.
Like I just decided at
some point that I was,
let me tell you the true answer.
I was losing coats all the time
'cause I'm quite
absent-minded, this is true.
I would lose my coat and
my mom would get pissed.
She's like, what the
fuck's the matter with you?
Because it would be every time.
You got a coat, take it to school,
and I'd be like, where the fuck's my coat?
(group laughs)
And it'd be over so then
finally I was just like,
you know what?
I'm not gonna wear coats anymore.
I don't need 'em and I
just convinced myself
that I'm, I don't know,
I've just like --
- [Colin] You're good with no coat.
- I just never wear a
coat so, I don't know,
what the fuck is that?
Jake?
- [Jake] Sounds like a mentality there.
- Right.
On the flip side, I do not
think I can mentality myself
to being the starting
quarterback of the New York Jets.
I do not think I can mentality
myself to sing like Beyonce.
I don't.
Do I think I can be a
better football quarterback
in backyard football?
Yes, I do.
Do I think I can be a better singer?
Yes, I do, but we have to
have an understanding of like
where the, where you --
- But wouldn't you rather
and I know your goal was not
to actually play quarterback for the Jets
but wouldn't you rather set
the massively audacious goal
and if you fall short of it
like I fell short of the Olympics,
you still land somewhere
and take what you've learned
along that way and develop it
into the next thing, right?
- Of course, if I was
interested in it, of course.
- If you were interested in it.
That's why I say to people,
set that audacious goal.
- But what I wouldn't
do which is what I see
from a drillion fucking
comments is then come up
with unlimited amounts
of excuses and blame
to why I didn't become Beyonce.
- Right, but aim that high,
engage the process a thousand
time, 10,000 times --
- Bro, I would be, bro, I believe,
my brain tells me
that I'm the president
of the United States.
Obviously, I logically know
that I wasn't born in this country
but like I really believe
that if I was born
in this country,
I would be the president of
the United States of America
in the next 20 years.
I really believe that.
- [Female] Let's go.
- I can't.
- If you had to go between
president or owning the Jets,
what would you do.
If you had to pick one or the other?
- You know what's funny?
My brain doesn't even work that way
'cause I can't be president.
I don't like make pretend.
That's like asking me
if I want wings and fly.
I am not allowed.
- It would be cool though.
- If I could, I'd fucking
win and I'd win big.
(group laughs)
I'd win big.
I just have, I just like
humans and they like me back.
- Yeah, respect, respect.
- Listen, everybody.
Please pick up this book.
It's important to India
and Colin too, I guess.
(group laughs)
Colin, thank you so much
for being on the show, man.
- Appreciate it, Gary.
Thanks for having me on.
- Good luck with the book.
Thank you.
- Yeah, I really appreciate it, thank you.
- [Gary] Bye bye.